welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Rick and Morty season 4 episode
3 one crew over the crew cruise Morty
reveals that Rick hates high steep lot
twists so much that he creates the
world's most elaborate heist one that
includes genocide just to stop Morty
from selling another heist to Netflix
with all the endless exhaustive
double-crosses it's a bit tough to keep
up with all the jokes and deep cut
references that are flying past us so
let's go back through this episode's
scene by scene for all the subtle
animation details you might have
overlooked boilers ahead let's get
started the episode opens with Rick and
Morty making their way through these
ancient ruins morty scales a cliff wall
while rick hovers beside him eating
lunch if you look closely the bag flies
past us you can see he's eating Arby's
and this whole gag was lifted from a
scene in Star Trek 5 the final frontier
in which Kirk climbs El Capitan and
Yosemite and Spock floats beside him and
hover boots
Kirk Falls and Spock saves them just as
Rick does for Morty here they zip up in
these anti booby suits to protect from
the booby traps and these ruins all a
nod of course to Raiders of the Lost Ark
including the boulder love that they
included the dunk when it hits them and
it's probably not important but I love
the detail that was put into the design
of these ruins and the ancient culture
at once was like notice the statues are
wearing backpacks and beanies and
headphones and they appear to be writing
segways as if this was some hipster
culture that collapsed under the weight
of its own smug and one of the travelers
makes total waste the snakes a nod to
these snakes and Raiders of course but
also to Rick's recurring use of snakes
and his trick where he makes people
think he can turn people into snakes I
always keeping a spare snake of his leg
instead of treasurer Rick is
disappointed by the contents just like
the Nazis were disappointed by the
contents of the Ark of the Covenant but
in this case it's a reference to another
Harrison Ford movie an origami horse
just like people work on a unicorn in
Blade Runner a calling card from Miles
Knightley a heist artist aka hipster
dick whose adventures are 60 percent
putting a crew together and 40 percent
revealing that the robbery already
happened and he's not worth our time
because he's a hack piece of [ __ ]
Rick's anti heist rant is actually based
on co-creator Dan Harmon's hatred of the
heist genre films like Ocean's eleven
inception now you see me and yes I would
argue the latest two MCU films
spider-man far from home and Avengers in
game both of which were centered around
heists but I went into the real reason
harman might hate Marvel and the reason
I'm sort of explained so go check it out
Marvel fan culture is definitely a
target in this episode though as they
head to
night police heist con modeled on
comic-con notice how it features its own
Hall H Rick's pride at one scene a
professional tear badge and refusal to
buy one is a joke about industry types
having too big an ego to buy a
convention badge
there are booths for pocket grappling in
nightly vision goggles and a nod to
ocean 12 an ocean 13 star Catherine
zeta-jones o siding with Catherine's
alpha through omega Joneses and the way
you enter is by cutting glass circles
like they do in high school easy the
attendees include cameos by the nerd
from blitz and chits in the morning
night run episode this guy's taken
really off the grid another guy he's
safe
he later snatches the mailbox that Rick
chucks the crystal skull into Rick tries
to check in as a professional he's a
getaway driver with Asperger's in my
butthole is a demolitions expert Rick is
referencing baby driver another heist
film in which the getaway driver has a
condition that some like described as
such and his demolishing butthole as we
saw his mecha-giant form to last episode
and rick assembles his crew with a jazzy
team assembly montage with music and
editing in the style of Ocean's eleven
each of his teammates he greets with a
hand grasped and a you son of a [ __ ]
parody in the trope from predator in the
Fast & Furious films the movie macGruber
also included a hilarious parody of this
kind of putting the crew together
montage it also ends with an abrupt
twist and I love how Clark got a gig
playing the piano when clearly his
fingers are way too massive to ever be
able to play piano keys Angie Flint
appears to be a lara croft inspired
heist ii adventurer with cybernetic
swiss army knife hands at rick Moxa's
impractical referencing his own super
practical cybernetic inserts that
actually show up later this episode and
then there's truculence tur truck in
which the monster is a vampire is a nod
to the putting the team together montage
and Ocean's eleven within Mormon
brothers who race monster trucks also in
this demo derby is a ridiculous banana
car and then after putting the team
together they return to get their con
badges notice how each badge has the
image of Knightley's origami horse in
Hall H we meet miles nightly voiced by
Justin Theroux
perhaps a nod to his pointless master
codebreaker character from the last Jedi
and he finishes a story of a recent
heist
police
stole the paintings because the police
were us in police outfits he's
referencing the heist in Ocean's eleven
which ends with the thieves disguising
themselves as SWAT officers and the
Thomas Crown Affair which features an
elaborate art heist
Rick bypasses security lab coat rip off
dr. strange Rick is referencing the
cloak of levitation from dr. strange
which also could be a nod by Dan Harmon
to his own uncredited work in the Doctor
Strange film in which she said that
Marvel used none of his ideas another
example of how this episode is targeting
both the heist genre and the MCU the
MacGuffin that Knightley proposes
stealing and the heist off is the
Crystal Skull of Horowitz reference to
the Crystal Skull and the crappy fourth
Indiana Jones movie and possibly Rick
and Morty staff writer Dave Horowitz and
we meet Knightley's ate a la ocean's 8
which includes snake arms double
microwave monitor Lourdes key catcher in
shapeshifter it's plus the three from
Rick's five which the number is eight
and five is kind of like yeah ocean's 8
and Fast Five their heist involves
swiping keys while pushing a hotel towel
cards just like the Ocean's eleven crew
did and in our vaults just like in
Ocean's Twelve and this vault contains a
parody of American Gothic but Rick
reveals that his real crew is really
just the robot heist Oh Tron and during
this we get a glimpse of the heist
screenplay that Morrie's writing with
the words approaches and his misspelled
there's also a lame twist about a dead
body being a cake before I continue
thank you - Monday comm for sponsoring
this episode
Monday comm is a team management tool
that's simple and flexible enough to
meet the needs of just two people
working together as well as vastly
complex workplace operations of
thousands spanning different departments
and time zones now I'm not sure if
Monday comm exists in the MCU but you
can imagine how helpful it would be if
shield could use it to assign tasks you
let Talos know which task he's supposed
to do is which human dude probably gets
confused Monday comm currently has over
80,000 teams on its platform from
startups to Fortune 500 companies like
McDonald's we use it at new rockstars to
centralize our editing process and
improve communication Monday comms
intuitive design uniquely flexible
structure and scalability has driven
teams at all kinds of companies to adopt
their platform they were even named
start-up of the week by Forbes Monday
comm aims to make every user feel
empowered and part of something bigger
than their own individual tasks and as a
result to boost productivity and
transparency
download Monday comm today using the
link in the description below Rick uses
hiset Ron to assimilate all 3,300
convention attendees to be in on it and
they rip house tightly to pieces as
always the violence is horribly graphic
they rip out his bones and grip cage and
skull leaving the skin as a droopy mask
another looter steals the head of
Abraham Lincoln not the head of the late
a bridge or Flagler from season one
different guy and a combat ties to Tron
from assimilating everything in
existence as part of his crew Ric
instead assembles a random team
including the return of mr. Cooper
butthole now professor poopy butthole
who Benton's off karate attacks with
students using his cane and slow-motion
berserk combat skills similar to hurts
in the Kingsmen movies they also recruit
the Greek god Hephaestus who works in a
volcanic Forge I love the detail that he
can lead their reflection in his hammer
and then they find ventriloquist us claw
an alternate reality Elon Musk
but with tusks Elon Musk actually voices
his character in this episode last March
he changed his Twitter name to Elan tusk
has a reference to his role in this
episode notice how Tom was designs on
his dry erase board feature coils
wrapped around tusks as if his tusks
were like the flux capacitor style
inspiration for his inventions meanwhile
hiset Ron applies lame obvious heist
tactics to steal a planet's core it
disguises itself as a security guy with
a nametag Hank a pizza guy with a
nametag
Tony he crushes the planet's surface
with a colossal security camera and a
pizza box that drills into it kills the
entire planets population I like how the
news-graphic says zero injuries and on
one of the screens one of the residents
was peeing in a corner at the moment of
this but the one resident we see
escaping is attacked by angry birds as
he flees into the mountains with
wildlife the whole planet gets wrecked
and looking back on this episode yeah
again we must acknowledge that Rick
committed a genocide just to stop Morty
from selling the script and Netflix and
Rick introduces Rando Tron instead of to
heist movies I slept through Rando
Tron's algorithm is derived from the
plots of three David Lynch movies I
pretended to like to make my friends
shut up yeah and Rick's mind the
narrative opposite of plot II contrived
heist movies is the surrealist non plot
stories of David Lynch like blue velvet
mahalo Drive and Twin Peaks
Rick passes the time by playing
Minecraft as he did with Morty in the
episode the Praetorian Morty dates and
due to ventriloquist knowledge of the
stars not being properly aligned
Rick realizes that the earth has already
been heisted with a night sky playing on
a pre-recorded loop a nod to the trick
that they used on Dennis Hopper in speed
a brief shot shows the earth in a
massive
rate of collective planets along with
other ones like Uranus with a bite taken
out of it
spikey Ramos it's got an Illuminati I
may be a nod to bill cipher from gravity
falls krump Bigham em nine nine nine
nine
Zippo big Pluto Mars fran drescher lekar
probably a nod to Fran Drescher tzimmes
slump and this has a big butt maybe it's
the butt to mention that we've seen
before and Schwing probably not to
Wayne's World and then in the lower
right corner
screwby something flew be doop yeah
probably another one of these nonsense
words it just to roil it just likes
improvised Randa Tron sends them all on
random bits of Estes eats precious brand
diapers and vomits groceries and then
does one-handed push-ups on the roof
then shrill aquiver runs in circles on a
polar icecap Tuscola puts a turkey in
the freezer then bakes the fridge items
morty subscribes to a boring looking
history of new york podcast and
professor poopy butthole runs a cattle
auction and all ends with rick
confronting highs to tron on his space
station heightening in a series of
impossible to follow double crossings
reference obviously to the NORAD AI
tic-tac-toe climax in the movie war
games and both heisted ron and brandon
tron are voiced by dan harmon all the
commentary about how robotic and
formulaic hi sorry's coming from his
voice directly morty makes his pitch
meeting at netflix which looks exactly
like the exterior of Netflix's actual
sunset bronson office in hollywood and
hallways there are posters netflix your
movie here and weirder stuff three four
yes stranger things three but we learned
morty losing interest in his own pitch
was all an inception style heist by rick
who waits outside on a ship just like
how brad pitt waits for clooney outside
the prison at the end of Ocean's eleven
to give him a ride and Rick eats a
lollipop throughout this episode as a
nod to Pitt in that movie who's always
eating candy and junk food in every
scene and finally in the post-credits
scene ex-professor poopy butthole
realizes that Rick must have trained to
all the students karate to attack him
and they see dark storm clouds forming
on the horizon and Rick says could be a
twister upon not just for a tornado but
coming additional twist
oh wow Morty twists a Rubik's Cube last
episode similarly ended with gathering
storm clouds we'll see if this storm on
the horizon
and is indicating some darkness looming
in on upcoming episodes the next episode
won't come out for another two weeks in
December but they will be titled claw
and hoarder special victims Morty
probably a murder mystery SVU episode
and rattle star Rick lactic ax a
Battlestar Galactica episode so let me
know what you think this post-credit
scene could be referencing in the
comments below follow me on instagram
and twitter Hattie a boss followed new
rockstars and socials and subscribed or
explained podcast feed to get early
audio versions of all this [ __ ] thanks
for joining me see in two weeks bye
[Music]